some of you guys are not gonna like what
I'm about to say but if you're a
millennial or gen Z and you've spent
your whole life hating your body and
scared to gain weight I'm going to share
with you an eye-opening reason why that
might be hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I want to talk about
how popular media has shaped our
perspective on being fat as well as
societies learn fear and discussed with
people who actually are fat also this
really shouldn't be a controversial
video but it probably is going to make a
lot of people mad I know I just find
like whenever I empathize with or even
just attempt to shed light on some of
the dehumanizing actions and beliefs
directed at people in larger bodies
people get kind of pissed like for some
reason raising Awareness on societal fat
phobia gets people really riled up and
it just feels like my message becomes
equated with me glamorizing obesity let
me make this super crystal clear here
I'm not downplaying any of the health
risks of carrying excess body fat but I
also don't believe that this excuses the
vitriol that I see against larger body
folks which has been proven to result in
discrimination and equalities in
education employment and health care so
definitely hit up my description first
disclaimer I will be talking about body
weights and dress sizes specifically in
some cases which I can imagine could be
triggering for a lot of folks to hear so
speaking of kids quick little story time
here last weekend I went for a facial
and my husband let my kids watch the OG
Willy Wonka I don't know I kind of
thought it was badly inappropriate since
the tunnel scene still really freaks me
the out and they were scared of
like Bowser in Mario Kart but yeah
typical dad move right there anyway what
my five-year-old took out of this film
was that the bad boy who got sucked into
the tube as he said was fat because he
ate too much junk I had a mini panic
attack because I knew that I had to step
up for a very big teachable moment in my
career as a mother but I also knew that
none of this was coming from within our
home like I actually never used the word
junk in my house and I kind of schooled
anyone that comes into my house who does
um I also would never associate
someone's body size with how much or
what they eat and I never associate any
of these characteristics with a child
who is bad this was learned through
media and maybe some bratty kids at
school oh Doyle rules
anyway this got me thinking a lot about
different movies and how they portray
fatness and also the profound effect
that this has on individuals and
societal beliefs about fat people so
when I was thinking about movies and fat
characters the first thing I realized
was that most of them aren't actually
fat like if the camera adds 10 pounds
Hollywood's portrayal of fat is also
really effing skewed basically one of
two things tends to happen in Hollywood
when it comes to Fat characters either a
thin woman plays the role and wears a
fat suit AKA Gwyneth and Courtney Cox
which is holy so gross and so
problematic and explicitly fat phobic or
an actress who is only slightly larger
than like the Hollywood standard is cast
and they're put alongside a cast of like
super uber thin actors and then we're
gaslit into believing that she's a big
girl and this is really where fat phobia
is more covert and sneaky but obviously
if you guys watch my channel regularly I
know you're now Gonna Catch exhibit one
everyone's favorite chronic Dieter
Bridget Jones and yes I will always be
just a little
oh boy like let's
let's treat on what's a bit fat Renee
Zellweger allegedly weighed just 130
pounds while filming with a BMI of 22.
that's a normal body weight folks yes
BMI is BS but that is the weight to
height ratio associated with the lowest
risk of chronic disease and yet her
character's whole personality is being
the fat one always trying to and always
failing at losing weight Exhibit 2
America Ferreira in Ugly Betty I mean
the name alone really says so so much
about what they're trying to portray
like I cannot say that this show has
aged particularly well but if you've
seen the show you know that Betty's
weight and looks are literally the
punchline of every episode she's always
eating the bad food that the models
won't touch and she's badgered by her
co-workers to try to lose weight all the
time and in this really truly grotesque
scene she's mocked when she's forced to
model in a tight revealing outfit
story but who the
who the wrote that episode and do they
still have a job inquiring minds want to
know another one that still bothers me
is when Samantha and sex in the city was
made fun of for her gut I said mother or
God what's with the guts
well she's eating something up there
I'm sorry what got at the time of
filming Kim Cattrall allegedly wages 137
pounds and is 5'7 again a completely
normal wait no wonder people
feel she is about their bodies oh Abby I
did not measure this properly but we are
going to revive it if my muffins suck at
the end of this I'm blaming you guys
because I definitely messed up the
measurements also remember Natalie in
the movie Love Actually AKA
the chubby girl
love that movie but again yikes he said
No One's Gonna fancy Echo with thighs
the size of big tree trunks not good
like despite being a straight sized
woman Natalie is frequently called
chubby or plumpy or described as having
a sizable ass and like thighs like tree
trunks it's up and perhaps for
the most asinine examples that I can
think of is Anne Hathaway in The Devil
Wears Prada I don't know what you're
expecting to do
there's nothing in this whole closet
that'll fit a size six I can guarantee
you FYI Ann's character is a size six
like that is a size small by the way and
yet she's described her at the movie as
being the smart fat girl and is ripped
into fruiting carbs and eventually
succumbs to the pressures to try to lose
weight like how up do we want to
make young girls who are looking at Anne
freaking Hathaway and thinking oh like
if she's fat and needs to diet I am
probably huge let me just remind
everyone that the average American woman
is a size 14 to 16. like these fat girls
in movies or anywhere between a size 4
and 12. and when the scripting doesn't
make like a big to do about their
fatness the public basically just fills
in the gaps so for example critics
called out Jennifer Lawrence in The
Hunger Games for not looking hungry
enough for the role likewise Melanie
Linsky was also called out for being
miscast for her role in Last of Us when
a tweet suggested that her body said
life of luxury AKA access to all the
food like what is embarrassing and
ignorant thing to say so yeah problem
number one most fat characters in movies
or shows aren't actually fat but the
other big issue that I saw when I was
really reviewing the media comes back to
what my five-year-old son saw too and
that is that fat people are often
portrayed in really undignified or
unflattering light basically we either
see them as gross and lazy or as
villains or the dumb sidekick or just
for simple comedic relief rarely are
they the protagonists or the characters
that kids like my son are supposed to
Aspire to be so for example back to
Early Childhood lessons much like
Augustus Gloop in Willy Wonka who
remembers poor little Brucie in Matilda
like the kid was also punished for his
gluttony and fatness now
eat it
so similar as to how Augustus is
portrayed he's like super sweaty and
he's messy and he's gassy and his
fatness is Central to what makes him so
naughty and even though in the end Bruce
does like Stick it to the Man or I guess
the woman in the case of mistrunchable
the message is still Crystal Clear
eating cake makes you fat lazy gross and
worthy of punishment and ridicule fat
people steal things fat people are
dishonest fat people are bad people do
not be fat and if they're not gross
they're the villain like Ursula in The
Little Mermaid is a great example of
that another is Jabba the Hutt like when
juxtaposed against the thin protagonist
it really sends a clear message to young
people that Finn is good and fat is bad
that there are character flaws inherent
in fat people and all we know is that we
just don't want to be them so gross
check villain check the last category
that I really saw often was the this
kind of comedic punch line again rarely
the star often there the dumb silly
aloof or gluttonous sidekick Fat Bastard
in Austin Powers is really a good
example of this grossness meets comedy
and I'm not a prude I actually think
that Mike Myers is genius in this series
even though I'm not sure that this movie
would really fly today but even a quick
reflection on the name the Fat Bastard
is associating fatness with like a
literal slur I really can't think of
many skinny actors or characters that
are farting excessively sweating
profusely and singing about unhealthy
food I want my baby back baby back baby
back baby back baby back ribs again it's
really not a very dignified look and
especially when held against the thin
fit midriff bearing Beyonce you can see
how it serves to like basically
reinforce a lot of the negative
stereotypes about larger body folks and
there are so many examples of this Amy
from Pitch Perfect Paul Blart from Mall
Cop like Chris Farley and literally
anything the bottom line is that fat
people's fatness is often their whole
personality in movies and shows they're
not particularly smart or cool or Savvy
they're fat meanwhile straight size
actors tend to get awarded a lot more
complex nuanced or human roles which
when you think about it is kind of
up considering that most humans
that are consuming this content look a
lot more like this than that obviously
there are exceptions to this and we are
starting to see larger bodied actors get
given more interesting or more layered
roles but generally speaking Hollywood
really has basically just typecasted an
entire group of people not based on
their talent but just based on their
size by portraying small bodied
actresses as fat and actual fat people
as these second-class Sidekicks or gross
or bad we get stuck in a little bit of
an echo chamber that honestly just is
not reflective of the world that we live
in that people aren't a size small that
people aren't necessarily all lazy or
bad I mean I know people don't like when
I use the word fat phobia because it is
uncomfortable to unpack our own biases
against people in larger bodies but even
if you are genetically thin or you've
worked really hard to stay fit and toned
that phobia and prejudice against
different body shapes and sizes really
doesn't serve you either like clearly
135 pound woman is being called out for
her gut this hurts all of us and it
increases the risk of body dysmorphia
eating disorders and other mental health
issues anyway that's my little media
analysis for today I do really
thoroughly enjoy this work because I
think it makes me a more Savvy consumer
and also makes me more mindful of what I
want my kids to consume or at the very
it just helps me become better prepared
for these much needed teachable moments
as they come up anyways I would love to
know what characters or movies I maybe
missed this was in no way supposed to be
some kind of like exhaustive list I
thought of so many more than this like I
could go on all day don't forget to
check out my new free Hunger crushing
combo ebook below and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]